cooing over new life
these babies are squid and octopuses
brought on border mothership by chance
clinging to an underwater camera this is
opportunistic science a chance to
identify the species and take DNA
samples for further analysis the
scientists on the nectar mission are
studying the seas of the Seychelles from
the surface down to 500 meters from
sharks to octopuses they're just
fascinating creatures they're so
different from us the way their nervous
system works I mean they've got like
many brains at the end of their arms so
their arms are sending messages and
acting autonomously and everything about
them is so different from us they're the
only you know the only really
intelligent thing that's really
different from us sometimes science is
simple dragging a net along the surface
allows researchers to assess the density
and complexity of life bobbing in the
waves this Hall produces thousands of
tiny blue crustaceans clinging to
seagrass
but scientists are also testing the
water itself to see what impact is
having on the environment but the deep
also fascinates the scientists and we'll
be using submersibles to explore the
oceans Twilight Zone with them
broadcasting the first live programs
from 300 metres below the waves is that
ripley completely unique ecosystem and
if it is does it need to be managed in a
special way are the animals that live
there the same as a powerful below it
are they completely different are they
do they just live in that area or maybe
it's the community of animals some some
shallow and some some deep but for now
it's the creatures from the surface that
have the limelight their alien looks
building intrigue for what lies in the
dark world beneath Thomas More Sky News
the Seychelles